[Music]
it's playing hide and seek
what do you think
yeah maybe hide and seek with you
what a waste of money
he's plain b if you ask me he needs a
rest
well maybe black nose is okay and then
he can go out
whether it's humans or animals you just
use them as you want
we never should have said yes to the
stupid plan what else can you do in a
zoo without any animals
then why don't you try putting on a suit
you gave yourself the easiest job here
i'm incompetent i frail as well
just get some rest no director khan
i ruined this i don't deserve any rest
can you please stop repeating that like
a broken record but it's true
i was the one who ruined this sue
it'd be fair if i die in a cage i'll
take over for you
and you get some rest
peace and quiet is the best thing now
for black nose
canada would be a lot better
i was trying to rest but two visitors
were staring at me the entire time was
like i was in prison
awful i thought i was gonna go crazy
maybe that's why black nose turned out
to be
so
all right i can
staring at us whoa
come on have a drink from the bottle
dum-dum
you're a dum-dum
it's your favorite hey buddy you like a
cola come on take a sip
oh no
hey come out yeah come here
are they gone
huh this is hard work
ah no way
ah damn it of course i'm gonna dive
first
the polar bear is really tricky
look at that
[Music]
dong park
the zoo and you'll be its director
what do you mean by that and how we
supposed to do that
this here is a zoo without animals then
we'll buy some new ones
how much do we need i know that i was
gonna check if there are any used tigers
on ebay
i have a really good idea are you out of
your mind
do you really think this whole thing's
gonna work we need very realistic
costumes
remember practice makes perfect
they should look really real put them on
no one would ever assume that there are
fake animals in a zoo they should look
as alive as possible
i'm your man
hey hello lion what the hell are you
even doing here huh this is so
stupid that looked really good you look
like a real gorilla
really it's going in the water don't get
your fur wet
that costs a lot of money
[Music]
a polar bear that drinks coke who ever
heard of that
[Music]
well maybe there were things that seemed
weird what kind of things
real gorilla probably escaped from the
zoo or something i don't know
is there security camera footage
the gorilla took it
[Music]
so
[Music]
you